[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there's a certain feeling of adrenaline
once you get up there in the air it's a
feeling unlike any other you feel power
you feel like you're in control you feel
special that's what makes trapeze
beautiful that's what makes the circus
beautiful my name is Christian Finley
and I'm a trapeze artist
15 years ago I was working for brewery
in Los Angeles I had a great life making
great money that had you know my Lexus
and I had a house I was only you know 24
years old a friend of mine told me that
she was flying trapeze and I said what
are you doing I want to come watch I
ended up taking a class and I was hooked
it was the addictive ride away and I
quit my life in LA and I joined the
circus I want some good pace 20 k just
had to give everything up pretty much
overnight and here we are 15 years later
I never looked back and I've been on the
road ever since to run away and join the
circus it takes commitment you have to
be ready for anything you have to kind
of live on your toes because you never
know what's going to happen your own
personal space your RV or whatever
that's your home and that's what has to
be stable inside whenever you're flying
trapeze you have to focus on what you're
doing and the moment you doubt yourself
in the middle of a trick most likely
you're going to mess up you're not going
to make it
the fact that I was able to do it made
it more appealing to me and I'm doing
these tricks and they're harder and
they're harder and this is awesome
whatever you want to do in your wildest
dreams do it anything's possible there's
not too many african-american female
circus performers but I was still able
to do it your life is what you make of
it and I wouldn't change my life for the
world I really wouldn't you get skinny
and then you want to cover it up I just
wore clothing baggy clothes things that
hid my body I would have little games in
my head that I would play like let's see
how long I can go without eating I would
definitely still be starving myself if I
had not found her bizarre i'm kayla dyke
and i'm a professional aerialist and a
survivor of anorexia I did gymnastics
and developed anorexia and my team into
my 20s at my lowest point I was 90
pounds and that's when I discovered
circus heart it changed my life because
I knew that if I wanted to do it I
needed to grow stronger and grow from it
it took me eight years to get from there
to here anorexia never really goes away
you just learn how to shut it out when I
look in the mirror now I don't see the
muscle mass I feel small almost
immediately I'm thinking you know that's
not true you can climb 200 feet straight
up I had no idea from my first day that
this would end up being my profession
[Music]
back then you know I would cook a pot of
noodles and I would have to get my
then-husband to strain the noodles for
me because I didn't have the strength to
lift a pot of water noodles and pour it
out and I remember asking what is wrong
with name and one on my trainers looked
at me and she said you need to eat I had
fallen in love with Ariel so much so
that I was willing to put food in my
mouth and grow some muscle so I can get
up in the air and keep up with all my
classmates
[Music]
I could say anything my anorexic silk
you see that you can be so much nicer to
your body at the time I thought it was
taking care of it I wasn't and I didn't
know any better
you
I'm capable of so much more
[Music]
my way of expressing myself as always
been physical when mom told me but since
I was little it's like if I would be
angry or happy or whatever you would see
it in my body language for me having a
new way of challenging my buddy and new
way of pushing the limits of what my
body can do that was the thing that
really got me hooked in flying my name
is in Bethesda and I'm a dancer and the
world champion indoor skydiver
I said a dancing when I was three years
old and as long as I remember a
fantastic when indoor skydiving came
along I found something for the first
time that I was more passionate about
than I ever was about dancing suddenly I
realized like I've just found in your
way of dancing is just on a different
kind of dance or the discipline that I
can feed in is called freestyle but when
I'm speaking about my flying over all I
prefer to use the term air dancing
because it's not just about competing
and that sector sizzlin it's about
creating something new exploring the
limits of what we can do in flying and I
would like to take flying from being a
sport towards being a form of performing
arts flying for sure is way harder than
it looks like the wind speeds can go up
to 180 miles an hour you have to be
strong you have to be flexible a lot of
the body positions look easy but they
actually require a lot to perform that
nicely so I split for example it might
look like I'm just resting in in that
flexible body position but I'm actually
all the time pushing against the air
flow you have control
I don't always like the use of the word
talented because it makes it sound like
only if you have that talent before you
even start flying you're going to get
good I've always been like a hardware
for myself so if I really want to get
good at something I'm going to do
whatever it takes it just depends on how
much you want it
Oh
[Music]
many people they understand it going up
it got me to the place where I just
wanted to disappear from the world I
wanted to be understood I just wanted to
be a part of the world test at that
would be my name without one hunter I'm
a director ganster ID and also I'm dead
[Music]
we who are deaf we can feel the fibers
we love all kinds of music but which I
want to feel it whatever you want to
play to play loud and take hope the view
that I give my speaker playing it close
to me we really laughs oh I memorized it
to my body I thought well I move that
vibrates invested my body stays of me I
think we're a desk duty
work with deaf people when i'm slightly
edgy shame and know how do you get their
attention to move to this tile that one
it's often for them and it's also for me
it becomes a quick will have to accept
it and I feel rejected or ignored oh I'm
deaf and I can be that when I cheering
clap for my death man there will be the
fourth year very damp international deaf
festival one is it director and the pile
of durable I realize with my
responsibilities to make a platform for
a deaf artists to be pradel it to the
world please performance give them a
real stay so real audience and will
speaker because dell we need allows i
[Music]
will ask to stay I've Alaska share I
don't want to be in a place where I can
express myself I want to share the truth
[Music]